Welcome to ear biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett,
this week at the round
table of dem lighting,
we're going to be sharing
our recent family adventures
that happened to each of us
over the Thanksgiving break.
Aha, I went to Disneyland.
I didn't.
So I got some fresh observations,
cause it's been a while since
I've been there my friend,
Well, you've been at Disneyland
at least three times more than I have.
That's my daughter's--
Since the last time I went--
She's a Disney freak.
I haven't been to
Disneyland in four years,
five years, probably.
How's your back?
Horrible
I could tell
when you walked in that
there was something going on.
Well, one of the things
that we'll talk about
is we actually spent
Thanksgiving day together.
Did you notice that my back
was pretty messed up on Thanksgiving day?
No.
I didn't...
So it was messed up the whole week--
You just seem so grateful,
that's all I noticed.
And it was starting to
get better by Thursday.
And then yesterday, we're
recording this on a Monday,
yesterday, Sunday after Thanksgiving.
I'm like, "I'm back"
What?
I'm back.
And I'm like, "My back is back."
Okay.
No more pain.
Do you know what triggered it?
I think I do, and then last night,
I'll tell you what I
think it triggered it.
It was back,
the back pain was back,
Yeah, but then last...
So I go to bed.
I'm like, "You got a big week."
We're doing some things that
we can't talk about yet.
And I tend to, whenever there's a--
When talk about it? Dammit.
The fact that it frustrates you so much
is I find very interesting. What--
Because it's the main thing on my mind.
Yeah, but I like keeping secrets.
I don't like not talking about things
that are on my mind.
Okay.
Whenever we're getting--
Especially when it's good.
Whenever we're getting
ready to do something new,
I've noticed a pattern that
my back will go out like,
"I'm getting ready to travel,
"and we're getting ready
to do this new thing."
So I've developed this ability
to just associate this stress or whatever
does something in the back muscles.
I don't know how it works.
Tension.
But what that has done for me
is it has let me not get too
stressed out when it happens.
So it's like, "Okay, this is temporary."
This isn't like--
Oh,
Gonna be around for months
and months and months.
It used to be around for a long time--
So you're stressed out, which causes it,
but you're not getting stressed out
about the back problems
because that would make it even worse,
and that's what's happened in the past.
Because I'm usually able to be like,
"Okay, you're gonna do your stretches.
"There'll be a few days."
Sometimes it might just be a few hours.
You never really know.
This one lasted all week.
And then, like I said, yesterday,
a full week later.
Now the thing I did tie it to,
the physical thing I tied it to
is a really intensive
bench pressing session.
Okay, now this might sound crazy to you.
How does bench press--
So far yes.
Intense bench pressing.
Affect your lower back?
I was doing like an
especially long session
and it was really intense.
And then...
What's wrong with you?
I'm just really showing
interest, go ahead.
But see, this is the troubling thing
is I never really know
because I can always, almost always tie it
to either something that I did physically
or something that's stressing me out
because I'm always doing things physically
that might hurt me,
and I'm always doing things in life
that might stress me out so--
Lifestyle man.
And so I'm like, "How did--"
Cause the Sunday night
after I did this bench pressing session,
I'm like, "Oh man, I'm really...
"Oh, this is a bad one.
"This is a deep one."
I call it ground zero when it goes back
to what I feel is like
the original disc injury.
Oh God.
And, then I'm reading a book
that I got about back injuries.
That's one of my pastimes.
And--
Does that make it worse?
In the first three pages.
The guy talks about avoiding bench press.
I'm like, "What?"
And then he explains where
the pressure comes from.
I'm like, "Well, must be
the bench press brother,
"but it could be the fact that
I'm a little stressed out."
Long story short, he
suggested doing pushups
instead of bench press.
Okay, so yesterday I'm better.
I haven't worked out the
whole week cause of my back.
So I'm like, "I'm gonna
do a hundred pushups.
That's a lot.
Not in one...
I'll do like 20 sets of five.
Okay, That works.
No, I do five set of 20.
20 sets of five would be moronic.
I do five sets of 20.
No it wouldn't,
sometimes you gotta start with...
And after the...
And so I did that and was fine,
all day yesterday.
Last night while sleeping, which is,
this is so common,
while sleeping at like 2:00 AM,
I wake up and I'm like,
"Uh-oh."
It wasn't like I rolled over
and it started hurting.
It was just like I woke up
because it was hurting.
Oh.
And I was like, "Oh no, man."
I was like, "okay."
And I tried to find a
comfortable position to sleep.
Couldn't really.
Did go back to sleep,
got up, did my like extra
long stretching routine
with the lacrosse ball
and all that stuff that I do every day.
Okay.
Took some Advil,
put some Bengay on there and I'll be fine
Well that makes me giggle.
I'll be fine. But I am glad.
I'm glad that the thing that we're doing
that's stressing me out
is not happening today,
but happening tomorrow.
And it does not involve bench press.
Yeah, and it's not a physical thing.
It's not like you have to be like...
Have a lot of lateral motion.
As long as I can walk, and...
In fact, I did that this morning
as I walked through the kitchen,
I was like, "Does it look
like something's wrong with me
"when I walk?"
And she was like, "Hmm, only if you know
"what you're looking for."
So when we talk about this
thing that we're gonna do,
that we finally get to talk about,
and we tell you the thing
that you can look for,
you'll know which one to look at
to then make a decision as to
whether or not you can tell
if my back was hurt.
But I'm gonna be fine,
don't worry about me.
I'm in top physical form
Mentally
but physically, boy, lemme
just look at me, man.
Good gracious.
Have you noticed how
I've been walking lately?
You'll be all right.
Just don't don't add--
The back panic.
It's nice to know
that you've got that
you've got in his place.
Because boy I remember the back panic
when you would just like...
You would be like, "Is this it?
"Am I coming to see you Ethel?"
Or whatever Fred Sanford used to say.
I'm not beyond traveling down to Panama
and getting some stem cells
injected in my lower back.
Just so you know,
that is still a top of mine.
Could that be monetized on YouTube?
Oh, hundred percent.
It will be when we do it.
Okay, great.
You should get some too.
It's not gonna hurt you.
Oh yeah.
I mean, I'll be there.
I'll get some.
I'll get some in the shoulder.
That's why I don't bench press.
Yeah, actually, you know what?
I'm gonna get some in my shoulder.
My shoulder, it pops out
and then it will usually go right back in.
And you can just get an
intravenously as well.
You can just do a full treatment
and you feel like Superman.
And you know what? Lily
has the same thing.
Of course, to transition
into my vacation here.
Daughter's back.
This is Lily's first
time back from college
for our Thanksgiving break,
so we we're looking forward to that.
The whole reason that we
planned to go to Disneyland
was because she is obsessed with Disney.
She loves Disneyland.
She's really into Marvel and Star Wars
and now that all that's folded
in to the park experience--
It's a smart move on their part.
I do want to tell you about
the specifics of that.
So we went for two days and the first...
We stayed in the hotel the first night.
We went to downtown Disney,
then bedded down for the night
for our first day at the
park, real fresh, real early.
So we'd get an absolute full day.
You stay in the park?
No, we stayed outside of the park
in just like hotel.
I was meaning like, wait till it closes
and like get under something.
No.
there's an urban legend that
Lincoln was telling me about
that there's like that Mark Twain island
in the middle of Disneyland,
he said, some people swam over there
and stayed all night.
It's not an urban legend,
that's true.
And then they--
Tom Sawyer Island.
Tom Sawyer, and then
they tried to swim back
with a baby and the
baby died or something.
I didn't listen too closely
because that was kind of
a downer early in the day.
But, just so you know,
I'm not recommending it.
You could easily stay inside there.
There's so many places to hide.
Now if you get caught,
you're in a lot of trouble
and a whole family doing it,
There's a lot at stake.
A family of five doing it?
You know what I'm gonna do.
I'm just gonna go sleep in a bed
and come back the next day,
and just buy a second ticket.
Finding a comfortable
spot would be difficult.
But that next...
The first morning, Lily said,
"I rolled over in my sleep
and my shoulder came out."
Oh man.
And I was like,
"Did it go right back on her back in?"
No
Because they're back stuff.
And I was like, "You know what?
"I've given you this.
"This is the genetic...
"This is the physiology of
how your shoulders are built.
"You're like me."
Sometimes I've rolled over in bed
or reach for something.
I thought that I had
damaged it in middle school
when you started taking
me to that bench press,
behind the bathroom at the law school
that your dad gave us access to,
and we would go bench press there.
And I would be pushing so much weight.
And then I would start laughing and then--
We would have laugh attacks
about bench pressing.
Then you would start laughing
and the bar would be on my chest.
And you couldn't get it off of my chest.
Cause I was laughing.
Cause you were laughing so hard.
And then sometimes my
shoulder would pop out
and I thought that's what
did it, but it's genetic.
But lemme stop you there.
I have developed a theory
and you are confirming it right now
and I've confirmed it multiple times.
Hey I'll confirm a theory if it's right.
98% of the time,
people miss-associate
whatever they're dealing with,
with a cause. Okay.
So I can't tell you how
many times people say,
"I got food poisoning,"
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah
And they're like, "I had--"
I agree with that.
"I was at the Applebee's last night
"and I got those riblets and
I've got food poisoning."
Right?
98% of the time
they're wrong because food
poisoning almost always
is associated with your last
meal, your most recent meal,
when it almost is never related
to your most recent meal.
It's kinda like me and farts.
And I've thought--
I'm always saying that I've farted
and you're like, "That's
not what you just ate,
"it's what you ate yesterday."
Yeah, but you've literally
gotten done with lunch,
thrown it away, come back in and farted
and been like "Oh, those
beans I had for lunch."
I'm like, "Dude, those
beans you had for lunch
"are sitting in your stomach.
"Nothing has happened in your colon yet."
Pushing gas through everything else.
No, that's not how it works. But anyway--
But food poisoning is sad
because then you're never
eating those riblets again,
and it's not the riblets fault.
But the shoulders popping out--
Was not the bench press,
it's just genetics.
Look it.
You're right.
And that is what I'm saying.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm saying,
but you forever associated it
with the bench press
just like I forever
associated my back problems
with bad dead lifting
in high school.
I was wrong, yeah.
I thought that I had stretched
out my shoulder stuff,
and then for the rest of my life,
it was popping out.
For those just listening,
who knows what I'm doing right now?
Oh gosh, this is why you need a watch.
This is why you shouldn't
watch the video version.
He's giving you multiple reasons
to not watch the video version this week.
So like father, like daughter,
her shoulders popping out too buddy,
But she's not experiencing back issues.
No.
I'm just finding it interesting.
She's not related to you.
No, but Link, she has a bionic spine.
I'm just interested.
Oh yeah,
Ain't nothing going wrong with that,
it's bionic.
I know. I'm just like,
She's not having any pain with that.
That's great.
Sometimes a little bit.
Okay, well there. Thanks.
I didn't know that's what
you were talking about.
Yeah, I just didn't--
You don't have a bionic spine,
But I might need one.
It's quite a recovery
for a middle-aged man.
Yeah, yeah. I'm not signing up for that.
Yeah, I don't want fusion surgery
unless I absolutely have to have it.
Let's do some ads for ourselves.
Okay.
mythical.com.
If you wanna get this
amazing color changing mug.
When you put in hot stuff,
it reveals a design.
And you see it on the desk,
could give myth a good morning
this entire past season.
Well, it's going away. It's going away.
At the the end of the year,
That's what happens,
the mugs go away.
If you want this mug,
you have to get it by the end of the year
because it's going away,
and it's very special.
If you wanna get this
"World's best boss" mug.
I'm assuming you just go
to Amazon and search it
because I just picked it
out of the cabinet in there.
I mean, it's a shitty mug
I mean, it's literally like...
I mean look at this.
Tell them to go to
amazon.com/mythical first.
We'll go to amazon.com/mythical,
make sure we don't sell it.
If we don't,
then you could probably...
There's multiple places where you...
Nobody has rights to this. This is stupid.
mythical.com, amazon.com/mythical.
But, again, for our mug,
mythical.com, get it while you can,
cause it will be gone.
Well just to get the physical
stuff out of the way,
Keep going.
Couple of weeks ago,
everyone in your family
got sick one by one, right?
Is that how I started?
It went through your whole family.
I felt sure it went...
We got it from someone in your house.
It was a cold,
and...
I don't know if you got it
from somebody in my house.
I thought we did.
Well all I--
Because we were asking how
long did Shepherd have it?
Shepherd's always got something man.
Shepherd's always got something.
He catches something
while playing video games,
I think is what's happening
And then--
He's getting the bugs from
the video games, but--
Then Lando got it, then Lincoln got it.
But one by one, it went
through your whole family.
Then I got it, then Christy got.
Okay, and so...
And that was a couple of weeks ago.
So leading into Thanksgiving,
on the weekend before Thanksgiving,
like the Monday Locke is
become sick with a cold.
Yeah.
And he has a fever,
and we're like, "Oh
no, man, this isn't..."
He did the test. It's not COVID,
it's just, there's so many
viruses going around right now.
Everybody's getting cold, right?
And so he felt like crap
for a couple of days
and then went and Jessie is sending out,
and Jessie is...
We've got a crowd that's pretty tense
when it comes to sickness in general.
Yeah.
The people that we were
having over for Thanksgiving.
Mm-hmm
And so, Jessie was like,
"I wanna let y'all know
that Locke is sick,
"he had a fever, but he's doing
a little bit better today."
And everybody was like,
"We wanna come to Thanksgiving,
"we don't wanna change plans,
"we don't wanna have a food exchange.
"This is what going for it.
"Just let us know how it
feels in the morning."
Then Wednesday as Locke's getting better.
Shepherd starts getting sick.
Mm-hmm.
Shepherd gets a fever,
like 101 or something like that.
102, maybe at one point.
Still, I don't know what the
discussion was at your house,
but Jessie told everybody
and everybody was like,
"We're still coming.
"Shepherd will just wear a mask,"
which he did,
and we ate outside,
which we were planning
on eating outside anyway.
California, baby.
That's why you move to California,
so you can eat outside next
to the pool on Thanksgiving.
Eat it.
Okay.
I love it here.
Meaning the food, eat the food.
Keep moving to Austin.
I love it here.
So we had that
and then Friday, Jessie
starts coming down with it,
and I'm like, "Oh no, no."
I'm holding out.
I don't even understand
how these viruses work.
I'm like--
I bet bench pressing
will keep it at bay.
Surely I got exposed
to this at some point.
Like, what's the incubation period?
Are we...
How is...
And so, first of all,
I'm doing everything
I can to not get sick,
for the thing that we're
gonna be doing this week
cause I would take hurt back over a cold
while doing the kind of thing
that we're gonna be doing any day.
So I'm like, "Man, I can't get sick.
"I can't get sick."
So I'm like, "Nah."
I'm kind of staying away from
everybody for the most part.
I'm like taking all kinds of stuff
that may or may not work.
I'm staying very hydrated.
I'm sleeping at least eight
hours every single night.
And so I feel like maybe I'm in the clear.
Jessie, she's almost
all the way through it.
They're all coughing like crazy.
Oh gosh,
They're just coughing everywhere.
Meanwhile.
Yeah?
You know, Lando was
diligent wearing his mask
except when he was taking bites of food
and keeping his distance from Shepherd,
except when they were
playing the video games,
after we were done eating.
Today, he is home from school,
With a fever.
Thanks to your family.
But
But hey,
the food made it worth it.
Hey, but this is the interesting thing,
because I thought that the virus
that went through your family,
which now you're making me think
that it came from my family to begin with,
was the same virus that
then got back to us,
but it's a different
virus because it came back
and now it's on Lando again.
Yeah, why would everyone
get the same thing twice
and within weeks of each other? I think--
So now you're susceptible to the new one.
I think I've been exposed
and I have made it out,
Yeah.
But your susceptible.
So you need to be on top
of everything. Hydration, sleep.
I'm in a tough spot.
Just stay away from your family.
It's surprisingly easy I learned
Where do you...
You stay in the garage bench pressing.
That's what you do
Yeah, just constant
bench pressing.
I mean, definitely knowing
what everyone was bringing
to Thanksgiving to eat
was a big factor in us saying,
"We gotta find a way to make this work.
"We're not gonna not have Thanksgiving."
Well, but we would have--
We could have had it
at our house.
There wasn't gonna be an
exchange of food though.
Oh really?
Just like last year.
Last year it was just us,
But
The McLaughlins
and the Neals at our house.
But we exchange food with the
Oh.
Yeah.
Cause they were on a strict
lockdown at that time.
But there was a food exchange.
So there was talk of a food exchange.
I didn't wanna do it. And that, of course,
I was the turkey man.
First of all, the sides were incredible.
Oh yeah.
And I kid you not,
I,
up until, actually right now,
I mean I had a smoothie
for breakfast this morning,
but every single day, since Thursday,
the only food I put into my body
is stuff from Thanksgiving.
For breakfast, lunch and dinner?
Nothing else.
I've only eaten leftovers.
Thursday...
So I ate leftovers Friday,
Saturday and Sunday,
exclusively.
What?
Nothing else.
You're speaking of breakfast.
Yeah, cause I--
You wake up later. You did a brunch.
I'm not eating right when I wake up,
I'm eating at like mid day.
Okay
And so,
I just had two meals.
I just had like a mid day turkey
and dressing brunch--
See this is the advantage,
we ran out.
It's the advantage of
having it at your house.
You ended up having...
You had to have had more.
Yeah.
And that's what you get
for having to...
You have to clean up everything,
but you get more leftovers.
William brought the mac and cheese.
And that mac and cheese was so good.
And there was so much of it.
I had mac and cheese last night,
and I texted him about it and I was like,
"Man, this is the gift
that keeps on giving."
It's good for the immune
system too. Gunk it up.
I thought about that,
and I think that on the whole,
I think the food I was eating
was better than other choices
I could have been making.
I mean, turkey's good for you.
There were some collards in there.
The sweet potatoes,
there's a lot of sugar,
but there's also a sweet potato.
That's good for ya.
There was some collards.
There's broccoli casserole,
which is still my favorite.
Broccoli casserole--
It has broccoli in it.
went real fast.
Actually, I was done with that on Friday.
We had that for three
days. I was able to...
Cause I took it back.
I took most of it back.
But man, it was so good.
When you've got, listen--
Christy special,
Nothing against...
You know, I already said
how much I love California.
I love California.
But if you're from California
or you been here too long,
you've forgotten how to do Thanksgiving.
I'm sorry.
Thanksgiving is not about being healthy.
It's about the food tasting good.
I'm not going to tell the story again
about the super California Thanksgiving
we went to that one time
where they did deconstructed stuffing,
which made me wanted to
physically hurt the guy
who served it to me.
We had two types of stuffing.
Oh wow, and they were both great.
One of them had meats in it.
Well the one--
Sausages in the stuffing.
The ones that Jessie made is based on--
Or the dressing if you will.
Her mom's recipe
and it's got hot and sweet,
like hot and maple sausage built into it.
And it's big.
And then the one that Jenny made,
is the classic one that
like my momma makes,
which I actually prefer the classic one,
but I ate the hell out of both of them.
And so, anyway, I'm sorry.
Again, I love California,
but it ruins your ability to
do Thanksgiving correctly.
You need to be from the south
and possibly the Midwest
to get this correct.
This is the worst time to
be giving this feedback.
It's like, we need to
be given this feedback
right after Halloween.
Just replay this.
But let me just talk quickly
about the turkey mishap
that I had because--
I didn't discern one and I ate the turkey.
I embarrassed myself in
front of my neighbors.
Oh,
At least I'm thinking I probably did.
I'm a turkey guy.
And I don't mean that by like
saying I really love turkey.
I'm saying that I'm the
guy that makes the turkey
for Thanksgiving.
Turkey's okay.
Yeah.
I try to make it as good
as it possibly can be
for the holiday.
I smoked one turkey
and I don't mean like a
rolled it up in a joint.
I put it on a grill
I guess that is what some
people might think at first.
But I don't think that's what--
Hey, it's California.
I feel like in California Thanksgiving,
you're smoking turkey.
It's like, "What do you mean by that?
"Is you're a pipe involved."
This means putting it on a grill,
a smoker, it's smoking it for
an extended period of time.
I did a whiskey maple glaze on this thing.
I took the entire breastbone
of the turkey out,
which is difficult
Beat that first,
that's always...
Just get it out of the way
And so I could
spatchcock the turkey,
put it really flat, so it cooks evenly.
It was great.
Actually, I made a little mistake with
it cooked faster than I wanted to,
I didn't get to crisp the
skin as much as I want it to
but set that aside.
I also deep fried two turkey breasts.
Okay?
Jenny, who loves white meat.
Our friend, Jenny,
she brought these two turkey breasts
and she likes a fried turkey.
So I was like, "Yeah, I'll do it.
"I'll get this electric fryer,
"it makes it super easy."
So I pull this thing out.
I've got the turkey...
The smoking turkey is smoking.
It's kinda doing its thing
and I'm like, "Okay, I'm ready
to deep fry these turkeys."
I got this electric smoker
that's like a big cube
and I had three gallons of peanut oil
that I was gonna use as my oil.
You said smoker, but you meant fryer.
Fryer. Sorry. Yeah.
It's a fryer, electric fryer.
So it's not one of the ones
where you put it over the open flame
and you potentially burn your house down.
Which I think I might
have to upgrade to that
based on this story I'm
about to tell you though.
So I'm like, "Okay, I'm
gonna fill this thing up
"with oil
"and
"turn it on."
So as I'm getting ready to pour the oil,
the three gallons of oil into the fryer,
I think to myself,
"I remember there being
like a valve at the bottom
"of this thing last year."
It's like a valve that you
can open to drain the oil
when you're cleaning it.
But it's underneath this mechanism
that's on the outside that
has the heating element,
so I was like, "Surely I
didn't not close that valve.
"What an idiot."
And so I just pour it in there,
and then I see that the
level's three gallons.
I'm like, "See, I told
you I closed that valve."
I turned around to do something,
to mess with the other turkey.
And I turn back around and
there is a pool of peanut oil
that is spilling out all around the fryer,
all on top of my outdoor bar area,
Glug, glug, glug, glug,
glug, glug, glug, glug,
Spilling down onto the concrete
and going into the drain.
Straight oil.
Hey, good you got to drain.
Straight to the ocean.
So I panic,
I pick up the heating element,
which is attached to
the control mechanism,
and I set the whole thing inside the oil.
I didn't even remember doing
this until later when I looked
and then I turned the
valve and I screw it up.
And then--
So you were able to find
the valve pretty quickly
when you needed to.
But yeah, but that was a lot of oil
that had already left.
And that was when I...
Now I have neighbors,
I have neighbors all around.
And this is the--
Do you have security cam
footage of this scramble?
I don't have an angle on that part.
I have an angle on the entrance.
I'da think you'da had an angle
on where you cook, so you
can see yourself cooking.
You kinda know where my neighbors are.
We share...
The yards are all kind of together,
but we kinda--
But they would have
to all look down.
They would look down on you.
Oh, it's not about them seeing me,
it's about them hearing me say,
Oh
just once?
No, I said it a couple of times.
I said it one time there,
and then I went inside,
told Jessie, I was like,
"I made a big mistake and
give me some paper towels."
And I was like,
"Do you have..."
Cleaning up oil is tough.
I said, "Do you have bath
towels that we don't need?"
Hmm. Yeah.
And she was like, "Yeah, these two."
Two?
she had two
that had like yellow stains on them.
It's just from the wood from the sauna.
So I'm like, "Okay."
I go outside,
and I start cleaning it up.
And then I look and I realized,
that's when I realized that
the whole heating element
with the control mechanism
Okay.
Is in the oil.
Even the electronics.
Like the dial,
the electronic part of it.
I pick it up
Oh you're having a--
Louder this time.
I'm sorry.
And I was so mad.
Like I get so mad at myself
when I make mistakes.
It's not healthy, I'm in therapy.
Is there any other word?
I mean, you were over the edge.
Yeah, and that was cause I held it up
and saw the oil pouring out
of the inside of the housing.
This is a fire hazard at this point.
And so then I'm like,
"I can't fry these turkeys,"
because what are you gonna do?
Plug in this fryer that's got
oil inside the electronics?
No.
Well, that's what I did,
and it worked fine
Well, I let it drain
for a really long time.
And then I was like, you have
to get oil very, very hot,
Like think about the way
a heating element works.
It's inside this thing,
and it's designed to heat the
oil up to like 400 degrees.
Yeah.
The worst thing that could happen
is the electric current,
which is what's happening
in the heating element to hook it up,
it's just gonna...
It's not gonna catch it on fire.
It's just gonna make it
hot inside the thing,
and it'll probably smoke and
maybe melt some of the plastic,
but I'll be able to tell.
At least that was my theory.
And I completely drained it,
completely wiped it down,
turned it on and watched it for 10 minutes
before I proceeded and it was fine.
Did you have the fire extinguisher ready?
I brought the fire extinguisher out.
Did you read it and say,
"Is this an electrical fire
one or a grease fire one,"
or "Oh, both."
I looked at it and I
couldn't come to conclusions
about that.
Yeah. You know.
I just know I Wasn't
supposed to put water on it,
but can you--
The thing I feel about
fire extinguishers is this,
if you got one that's that
is a victory and just use it,
and see what happens.
And you could say that you did your best.
I don't...
We need to look that up because--
Yeah, we should
Is it bad
to put a fire extinguisher
of any kind on a grease fire?
I know you can't put water on it but--
#EarBiscuits, just let us know.
But I will say
that a couple of the
families that live around us,
I believe our grandparents.
Because during the holidays
you'll hear children.
And during other times you
don't hear the children.
It's either, they're a normal family
that only lets kids
outside during holidays,
which is possible.
Or it's grandparents, you're
only having kids over.
So they learned a word.
And so I think that yeah,
there were like,
"That man down there is having something,
"something's wrong with him."
But it turned out good
Is there a grease stain
on your concrete?
Cause that's tough.
You know what I did?
I've had some oil mishaps
on this surface already.
Okay.
So what I did
is I took one of those bath towels
and I polished the entire
surface with the peanut oil.
Oh.
And it just evened it out.
Like it never happened.
I bet it smells good out here.
It does. It smells great.
Just don't smoke a cigarette out there
You want to talk about Disneyland?
Yeah.
Yeah. So the first day we went to...
I always want to call
it islands of Adventure,
but that's the Universal thing.
And because that was in my head,
I can't call it the right thing.
Where, when Mythical was smaller,
we all went to--
What's the car's place?
What's it called? Adventure,
California Adventure,
California Adventure.
Yeah.
That's what it's called.
We went there on the first day
and then we went to Disneyland proper,
on the second day.
I had not been to Islands of Adventure
since California Adventure,
I haven't been to the adventure.
Yeah.
Since
they made Avengers Campus a thing,
there's a--
Where is that?
You go in and you hang a left.
Was it something else?
It was something else
that wasn't memorable.
And it had--
It didn't replace Indiana Jones, right?
Indiana Jones--
No, no, no,
That's in Disneyland.
So Tower of Terror has been revamped
as a Guardians of the Galaxy ride.
Oh, the ants, the Antworld
Antworld.
That's gone.
Ant's ride is gone.
That was a big area that had like...
You could walk through,
there're kids stuff
Yeah, and you seem like...
It was like, "Honey, I shrunk
the kids" kind of a vibe.
It was time for that to go
Right.
See, we never went there.
They changed that into Avengers Campus,
and then the pier part
with the roller coaster
and the big Ferris wheel
and the water.
And the corn dog castles
And the corn dog castle that you love.
They're not getting rid of that.
Corndog castle is still there.
They're never getting rid of that.
That's the pinnacle of the park.
I almost got one, but I didn't.
They changed that Pixar Pier.
And then there's like those rides--
So Carsland kinda got
extended out into the--
Carsland is still its own thing.
But I was most...
I mean, we went to California Adventure
and they made that rollercoaster
into an incredible steamed rollercoaster,
but it's the same rollercoaster.
And Christy was very proud of herself
cause she went on that,
but she didn't tell us
how petrified she was,
that she was overcoming something
The wooden roller coaster.
Yeah. Not a huge fan of it,
but it, but it was fine.
But at the Avengers Campus,
there's this brand new
Spider-Man ride that like...
I don't know if you know,
on Pixar Pier,
there's a VR ride
where you're playing
all these carnival games
with 3D glasses on
and it's like Pixar
Toy Story themed stuff.
And that's really awesome.
That's been there a while.
The one where you're shooting?
Where you're shooting
rings and stuff and--
Oh, that's amazing
Keeping the score.
That's amazing.
Well, they did a Spider-Man ride
that is basically the same approach
but instead of using a canon
that you're actually pulling
on something physical
and then these imaginary
3D rings are coming out,
you just throw out your hand
as if you're casting a web,
like you're Spider- Man,
phew, phew, phew, phew.
You don't have to make
the noises, but I did.
And it just--
Did you feel
like it's accurate?
It's pretty accurate and
you're throwing 'em...
And so you're on this track
and you're zinging around
and there's all these set design,
but then all these screens,
and it's 3D glasses and all that.
We waited for like an hour and a half
to get on that ride.
It's not worth more than an hour.
They've done away with the Fast Pass,
That's gone.
Having been there now...
Why did they get rid of the Fast Pass?
It was just becoming clogged?
I didn't research why.
Is it like a traffic issue?
Is everybody going to the Fast Pass?
Who knows all of their reasons.
But if you have an annual pass,
you can then get something
which will give you a
comparable experience
to Fast Pass, I think.
But because I couldn't get that
and we don't have annual passes,
we just waited in line.
But that was way too long for Spider- Man,
especially when halfway through the ride,
I was so exhausted and I was pretty--
Shoulder popped out.
I thought my shoulder was gonna pop out.
Right
Both of them,
like I'd come out of the
thing just limp-armed.
Just the rest of the day knuckle draggin.
You gotta be careful
when you got that Neal physiology.
Right, Mm-hmm.
Can't be Spider-Man.
But the Tower of Terror turned
into the Guardians of the
Galaxy ride was amazing.
I woulda waited 90 minutes for that.
Still works in the same fashion?
Yes.
Mechanically, it's this...
You get on, basically an elevator.
And then the doors open and...
The elevators falling and rising,
and the doors are opening
at different levels,
and you're seeing different video screens.
But the way that they themed it...
In Guardians and in some
of the other Marvel movies,
like Benicio Del Toro
played The Collector.
And so they turned the whole thing
into The Collector's museum.
So when you're going through the line,
there's like all these specimens,
plant specimens,
weaponry, all of this stuff
from the Marvel cinematic universe
that he's collected--
To kinda make the line not as bad.
Yeah.
And that was cool.
And then you get in there,
and he's captured the guardians
and then they're each on display.
So then you've got to get them out
by getting on the elevator.
This is the main opening
And sitting there.
Well, the premise is
you're just there attending the opening
of his new exhibit, which
is seeing the guardians.
So it's really cool when
everything in the line
and everything leading up to it does that,
but then when you get in there,
yeah like Rocket escapes.
Is it the real actors doing all of it?
Yeah. As far as I can
tell, it sounds like it.
I think they've--
Oh, well yeah, definitely.
There's footage of all of them.
That's like for the ride.
This point that's gotta
be in the contract.
Yeah, I'm thinking so.
Cause you know
back in the day,
They didn't do it.
You'd show up at the ride.
I ain't doing no ride.
It's like, "That's not Christopher Reeve."
Right.
Or whatever it was.
It's definitely what's his
name from Parks and Rec?
Yep, Chris Pratt.
Yeah, him.
You couldn't remember Chris Pratt's name?
You know, he's definitely in it,
and Zoe Saldana.
I'll remember her name any day that week.
Yeah, right.
And if you gave me her phone number,
I'll remember that too.
I doubt that.
Nah, I wouldn't,
I don't remember phone numbers anymore,
you just store them in your phone.
Yeah.
That was all a joke anyway.
Anyway--
If you had to--
The theme,
If you had to meet her,
would you rather her be
as who she is or green?
Oh, green. That would be awesome.
Right.
And then I'd know she really worked for it
to meet me.
It's like, "Oh, you put an hours."
But just because I said
I wanted to meet them.
I was on the jet bridge,
The green version?
With her
and her man one time.
I remember that. You told me about it.
That ride was thrilling.
Again, it's the same ride physically,
but I've never experienced the
theme being placed on a ride
and it making it so much more satisfying.
Yeah, and you know,
there's a lot of purists
who get upset about that kind of thing.
Who are like, "Tower of Terror's
been completely compromised
"because they made it the Avengers ride."
I don't see how anyone could complain
because it's so much more amazing.
And it's so, I mean that was--
If it can be complained about, it will be.
My second favorite ride.
And then towards the end of the day,
we timed to go in the Cars Line,
which was over an hour.
That's a good ride.
But when the sun setting on that,
the set design and that world is just,
it holds up so many years later
and it doesn't even matter if you've--
It's like it's a real desert.
If you've seen the
movie. It's so beautiful.
And then you get on the ride
and you're like, you're in the car.
And your joy riding through this.
And you're just looking around
like, "I'm in monument valley."
It never gets old.
I love that.
It's so great.
So that's my third favorite ride.
But on the second day,
we went to Disneyland.
Hold on, so you didn't go on Soarin?
We did go on Soarin.
I love Soarin man.
Soarin takes you around the world.
I love it, man.
It's not just California Soarin.
It takes you around the world.
And you smell things.
And you smell stuff.
What kinda stuff you smell now?
Oh man, I gotta go back
Grass.
You smell grass?
When they went over the orange fields,
in Soarin
You don't smell any orange
The citrus spray?
You're wearing a mask now.
You've gotta wear a mask inside,
with all this pandemic stuff.
Have you heard about it?
So you're wearing a mask
Something's going around.
You wearing a mask the
whole time you're in Disney?
No, just inside.
Or just when you go inside.
Just inside.
Is a rollercoaster
considered inside?
Like Space Mountain's inside a mountain.
No,
I think you're moving too fast
for the virus at that point,
It can't keep up with the rollercoaster.
Well, Space Mountain, I didn't ride that.
So I don't know if they
made you wear the mask,
because that is indoors.
You probably did have to wear the mask.
But I won't know.
The second day I was like,
"As long as I can ride the
Rise of the Resistance,
"which I have never ridden,"
I have been Galaxy's Edge.
Like the Star Wars world.
I thought you rode it
the first time you went?
No, just the Millennium Falcon ride,
but Rise of Resistance,
But it wasn't done when--
Lily had been on it but...
No, they wasn't even talking about it
the last time I went.
And of course this ride
is built up so much
to the point where I'm like,
"Okay, I know that it says
"that it's a two hour wait for this ride,
"but this is the best theme
ride on the planet potentially,"
from everything I've heard.
So I'm not gonna wig out about it.
I'm just gonna get in line.
And first of all, talk about
the lines and the walking,
like--
You're not ready for this.
I was not ready
You need a pair of wheelies
For being on my feet all...
It's by the...
By halfway through the
afternoon of the first day,
I had to sit down and I was eating a taco,
and then I was like,
"Aye, y'all just go and do some stuff,
"I'm gonna sit here."
And I went to sleep.
Christy sent a picture
of you to our group chat.
And you were just sleeping.
I was sitting up.
No, there was one where
you were lying down
Yeah, I ended up lying down.
It was like...
Well, first I took my I took
my shoes and my socks off.
And she was like, "This is a restaurant."
And I was like, "This isn't a restaurant.
"This is just some tables outside."
But what if everyone did what you did.
What if everyone took their
shoes and socks off at Disney--
I saw a few other people doing it.
So it's not like something I invented.
Okay.
Lemme tell you.
I was in a corner,
on my right was nothing but plants.
There was talk about escorting you out,
just so you know,
between Herb from Omaha, Nebraska
and Dale from St. Louis, Missouri.
Cause it says it on their nametag.
They were like,
"we have a barefoot.
"We have a barefoot situation."
I mean, people walking around in sandals.
We'll give them another seven minutes.
People kick off their sandals.
I just kicked off my shoes and my socks
and I needed to man.
Kicking off socks is never
good man for everybody else.
I'm sure it was good.
I felt bad, but I was desperate.
And then I was like,
I just have--
This is day one?
Day one. I was hurting man.
And I was just sitting there and then,
it was a chair,.
And then once they got up and left,
then I moved over two more chairs
and then I just laid down
and literally went to sleep
for at least 20 minutes,
and boy I needed every second of that.
This makes me think about,
there's a couple of
potential modifications
that they can make to the line.
Now obviously they're doing a lot
to make the line more entertaining
because they're making
it as museum or whatever.
So there's interest factor along the way.
But that only goes so far.
Two ideas.
Number one, is provide a way
for people to just lie down
and slowly be pushed,
I love that idea
Take your shoes and socks off,
and just slowly be pushed.
Some people are in those motorized carts,
but why can't everyone?
But just something...
Yeah, I mean something for everyone
that doesn't take up too much room.
Second potential option.
And I know there's people who
take this into their own hands
and they come up with like a game to play
while they're in line.
I kind of feel like--
Yeah, the heads...
A lot of people were
playing the heads up game.
But maybe Disney could actually Create
Line games
Line games.
That's a good idea.
And they bring them to you.
I know an Imagineer
who works in the parks.
I mean, I could make a phone call
and I could suggest this
and then maybe get 10%.
I saw the people doing heads up,
and then I just felt like,
if I did that, it wouldn't
be an original idea.
As a family, we never even
talked about doing it.
But if you're in the Star Wars ride line,
this is the game that
you can play in the line.
And it's just like...
The line is suited to it somehow.
I did notice the one thing that they did
even when the line was like 90 minutes
and that's really what
Rise of Resistance was
once we got in it.
Now I will say it ended
up only being an hour.
So it moved faster.
The thing I noticed was--
That was manipulation.
Yeah, they raise the bar and
then they make you happy.
Yeah. Low expectations man
The line never stopped moving.
It wasn't stop and start,
stop and start.
And there were even some
benches placed along the way,
but because the line never stopped,
you couldn't sit on a bench.
So I found that interesting,
but it did help a lot psychologically,
but what it didn't help
with was like by day two,
when it was my nap time again,
here I am in this line
and I can't even sit down for a second.
So, and I'm just...
My hip flexor is just hurting.
You're talking...
First of all, you started off this episode
talking about your physical form,
or your physical peak or whatever.
Yeah that was a setup,
this is the payoff.
Oh, okay. Got it.
And so the only thing
that would give me relief
was deep squats.
Like if I really squatted down,
my hips would open up a little bit
and I'd start to feel better.
But the line wouldn't stop so I had to...
And I didn't wanna just
keep squatting down
and squatting up.
So when I squatted down
and the line moved,
then I just started duck
walking behind the line.
And I experienced lots of relief
and ridicule from my family.
I didn't realize it,
that Christy was posting
this on her Instagram story.
Oh she did?
I didn't realize it until the next day,
that like my duck walk
and my napping session were
posted on her Instagram
Here's the thing Link.
You are free to make all these choices,
but others are free to
ridicule you for them.
I mean, that's what
America's all about, man.
Desperate man.
I would've stripped down naked
and done like the anus dog drag if--
Was anyone else suffering in this way?
I'm not saying that my anus was itching.
I'm saying if it was to the point
that I was hurting in other ways,
that's what I would have done.
Did you get recognized?
Well, okay yeah. Was anybody else...
Well, I'll answer that in a second,
but the question I thought
you were gonna ask,
was anybody else doing
anything worth ridicule?
Yes, I'm not alone.
There was a guy in front of me in the line
and he had a full sized ziploc bag
with a rotisserie chicken in it
Okay, that's worse.
And he would open the ziploc bag,
and he didn't buy the
rotisserie chicken at the park.
That's not being sold.
Well, first of all, that's illegal.
You can't bring in chicken.
Christy ended up talking to him.
And he said that his
grandma made a chicken,
and then since they
were coming to the park,
he said, "Well, I'm not going
to give up grandma's chicken."
And so he brought it in his ziploc bag.
Has he heard of refrigeration?
And then he opens a ziploc bag
and then he just starts eat...
He doesn't--
He's eating wet chicken
out of a--
Yes. He doesn't touch the
chicken with his hands.
He just eats out of the
gap in the ziploc bag,
eating around the bones and
then he would open it up
and offer it to his older sister.
She's like 17 years old.
Oh, how old was he?
Like 15.
Okay.
So he was offering his gap ziploc bag
with rotisserie chicken to his sister
who was doing the same thing.
It was like feeding the horse.
Yeah.
It's like feeding a freaking horse.
It runs in the family.
You should be happy that
chicken bag was close to you
because it was a great cover cause--
Yeah,
chicken bag and duckwalker
Cause squatwalking man--
We're a super hero duo right there.
Put us in The Collector's museum.
He can get away with anything
if chicken bags around.
Rise of Resistance was
a 20 minute experience,
which is pretty crazy.
And it start...
I mean, it's this entire story
that I kinda don't want to tell all of it
because I don't wanna spoil it for people.
Is it not a story that exists somewhere
in an existing piece of IP?
No, it's a particular
time when General Hux,
you know the guy from Ex
Machina, who's not Oscar Isaac,
the red haired guy.
Yeah.
And then Kylo Ren are like...
They're the main characters
and you're on this resistance transport
that gets hijacked...
Well that gets intercepted by them
and taken into their ship.
You know, that was tough
for Adam Driver to do.
Well, you never saw Adam Driver's face,
you just saw the mask.
And I don't know if it
was his was his voice.
It wasn't.
Dude, Adam Driver,
first of all, he had to
swallow a lot of pride
just to be a part of
the Star Wars franchise,
but when they said the
ride thing, he was like,
"As long as I don't have to do the rides."
Oscar Isaac was in it.
Oh, Oscar will do anything for a paycheck.
Oscar's great man.
No, no. I'm just kidding.
Daisy Ridley was in it,
shoot the guy who played...
Anybody who shows their face.
Yeah.
And so we're on the...
So it's this whole story of
like, you get in a transport,
but then it gets a tractor beamed,
that's a Star Trek,
but it gets tractor beamed
into the Kylo Ren's ship.
And then you're inside of the ship
and you get off of the thing you were in,
like the simulator.
and then you're walking in this...
The expanse of this thing is this huge.
You're in this huge,
like there's a whole
freaking hangar full of ships
and stormtroopers,
and they're like,
"All right, move this
way to be interrogated."
And you're interacting with actual people.
So it's like you're entering
into the world itself,
which is the whole point of the--
Completely immersive.
And so you get strapped into something,
you're in a VR environment.
You get unstrapped,
You know, the guy that.
You're walking around.
I could walk anywhere.
I coulda ran through a
bunch of star troopers.
Star troopers, stormtroopers,
and just like gone nuts.
Well, so
On this place.
The guy that--
I was not restrained,
I coulda duck walked all over
You know the guy that I'm talking about.
He's friends with...
Our family knows him, but you've met him.
But he told me all about,
not that he needed to tell me details,
but basically when he's talked
about Star Wars four years ago,
Yeah
He would be like,
"It's gonna be crazy.
"It's gonna be like you're
walking into the movie."
Oh gosh
And I was like,
"Yeah, that's what they think.
"But they're gonna keep
you restricted and stuff."
But you're saying that you can--
That you got off of a ride,
you were walking around a hanger,
being ushered into another place,
and then you--
But what if you did?
What if you went crazy?
What if you did start running?
They'd shoot you?
Yeah. I mean, there's lots of weaponry.
You get zapped. And they
probably just make it...
They were probably ready to
make it part of the thing.
They wouldn't take their...
No one with a name tag would show up.
Stormtroopers would take care of that.
Well you were a prisoner
being interrogated.
At one point, we were put into a cell
and then Kylo Ren comes in
and he's about to let us have it.
But then he gets called
into other business,
and we get rescued from.
Hold on, hold on,
but when Kylo Ren,
is it a dude in a costume?
It was a screen at that point.
And then at other points,
it was animatronic
versions of him and Hux,
so that it was very mixed media.
Everything that Disney has
ever done in a theme ride,
at different points, you
experienced all of it,
and more.
Super impressive.
I can't remember the last time
that I've just walked around
with my mouth gaped open
for eight minutes straight.
Yeah, you shouldn't do
that during a pandemic.
I have a mask on, no one could tell
that underneath my mask,
I was just gaped open the whole time,
like that ziploc bag with
the rotisserie chicken in it.
Yeah, was chicken bag with you?
chicken bag got interrogated
in another room,
Did they take his chicken bag?
They should have taken him out for that.
I think he was zapped,
but I think they would have...
I mean, if you'da cross some lines,
they probably woulda
kept that part of the...
I think there's a threshold,
at which point, there's a level one.
There's like a level one.
We can keep the narrative going.
There's a level two.
Okay, level three is when
the narrative breaks down
and actual Kurt from Missouri comes in,
and takes you out
You're right.
I was so amazed,
I didn't wanna push the
boundaries of anything.
Or you couldn't physically.
I wanted to experience it
because it was meant to be--
You couldn't move fast enough.
But was I recognized?
Because of your problems.
You know, I have this mindset that like,
"You know what?
"I'm gonna let Lily be in charge."
She's been at all these Disneylands.
I'm not gonna be in charge of,
"Okay, we need to get up at this time,
"we need to get here, we need to go here,
"we need to get in line this way,
"we need to minimize
how long we're in line,
"and we need to eat at this time. And..."
You know, I really tried to
totally relinquish control,
empower her and be done with it.
And I think the report
on that is pretty good.
You know, I did pretty good
Pretty good.
I have some notes, but I'm pretty good.
She's a lot like me, so
she had a lot of opinions.
I think that made it
where we didn't fight.
Nobody really fought
because everybody was like,
"Okay, this is, this is Lily's world."
And you see everything
that you wanted to see,
Two days is really what you
need, I guess, at this point,
with all that stuff and all the waiting.
Yeah.
We still saw everything we wanted to see,
but I didn't get recognized as
much as Lily got approached.
Like on day one, she,
she cosplayed as Loki
and going into the Avengers stuff.
So she had been Loki for Halloween.
And then she did a version of that,
so like all these people,
some other people who were fans of Loki
or dressed up like Loki as well.
Like she made friends
with a couple of girls
that were all dressed up like Loki.
So people were coming up to her,
"Hey, where did you get your
Loki ears?" or whatever.
And then the next day
we went to Star Wars.
So she was your proverbial chicken bag?
She was, yeah.
When it comes to getting recognized.
Right
You gotta have something.
She was a Asoka the next day.
She made her own Asoka Tano--
What is that?
It's this female character
from the Star Wars universe
and she was most recently the Mandalorian.
She showed up towards the end.
Oh, yeah, okay.
And she's gonna have her own show.
And if I showed her to her,
you'd recognize her.
Yeah.
Rosario Dawson plays her now.
She made her on ears
and people were coming
up to her the second day,
and more than came up to me.
But when people came up to me,
of course, they all called me Rhett.
Yeah.
Which happens
Keep it that way.
I've been called Link many times.
Really though?
Yeah.
Okay.
Makes me feel better.
I've been called Link by people
who I'd been with for hours.
I think that if you're just meeting,
you're probably gonna say the word Rhett
versus the word Link
to associate both of us
when you don't really know who's who.
But that's what at least
what I tell myself.
But the thing that never
happens that did happen
was I was seated somewhere
and somebody came up to me
and the first thing I saw
was somebody put a phone in my face
and it was a picture of us.
And then I looked up and the guy said,
"This wouldn't happen
to be, you would it?"
Oh, that's an interesting tactic.
I was like,
"Yeah, I'm the one on the right."
And I'm like making a face like,
"This is super strange." And he's like--
People don't always have a good plan.
Yeah,
that's kinda the thing you
have to plan out a little bit.
I'm gonna Google and I'm gonna...
I guess he had confirmation,
but then he even wanted me
to confirm it, which I did.
It was just strange.
I have a quick holiday recognition story
now that you've told that
one that I just remembered,
I had to do a little shipping,
and so I had to do some like--
Some boxing--
Some tracking shipping.
Shipping that needed to be tracked.
And so I go to the local...
I guess it's a UPS store,
and of course, we're in holidays, I mean,
Bonanza.
It's like,
there's seven people in
line when I get there,
and I'm like, "Oh gosh."
And everybody's got a different request
and the guys working
there, you know, teens.
And nothing against teens
I'm standing in line
for an hour and a half.
Dude you're complaining
about seven people in front of you?
Well--
I mean, did your duck walk?
I hadn't planned. No, I didn't.
I experienced no physical discomfort.
Okay, there you go, see.
But when I get up to the register,
the guy is like...
Silence?
There's silence,
and there's big eyes.
Okay
I'm like, "Oh no."
Cause now there's seven people behind me,
everybody is in a holiday mood,
which is not a good thing usually
when you're mailing things.
And then he's like, "Rhett?".
I'm like, "Yep."
It's like, "Now's not the time."
And I'm like, "Dude, I don't
want to do this right now."
And he's a big fan,
and I appreciate that.
And he ends up...
Okay, listen,
I'm not trying to sound like a douche bag.
It just happens.
Which may,
but sometimes, I've experienced
this multiple times,
that when somebody who is
doing a service for you,
whether they're giving
you food like a waiter
or they're checking you out of a store
or they're shipping something off for you.
If they're very excited,
if they're a fan and they're very excited,
that's 99% of their
brain is focused on that.
And now the 1% is focused on the job
that they're doing for you,
which in this case...
Actually, this was very important,
that these two checks that I was sending--
Oh yeah.
Got to the right places
at the right time.
Okay
And I'm like, "Dude, don't..."
Cause I'm--
And you can tell
it was falling apart.
I can't tell you how many times
my order has gotten screwed up.
So many things have gotten
screwed up cause it was...
And I appreciate people being fans.
I'm huge fan of fans. Okay.
I love fans and I love
the people are fans.
You're doing great.
But when they're doing something for me
and they screw it up
because they're a fan,
it's just frustrating.
But most of the time, it's just like,
"Oh, you gave me meatloaf
and I ordered fish."
I can eat that, it's fine.
But this was like,
"If you screw this up,
"it's gonna mess my life
up a little bit right now."
in a way that I don't
want it to be messed up.
So,
he's doing his thing
and then he's talking to me,
he's kinda giving me his resume.
You know, "You got any open positions?"
Going into that, giving me the resume.
And I'm kind of explaining the...
Like, I don't really...
I don't do...
I don't accept applications.
That's not how it works anymore.
But here's what you...
If you're interested, there's postings
and I'm like trying to be helpful.
And then he's like, "Okay,
well, can I get a picture?"
I'm like, "Sure, man."
Of course I'm being nice.
Not being an asshole.
I'm thinking about all
the people behind me
who are impatiently
waiting, patiently waiting.
Maybe they were impatient.
And then he's like, "Can I get a picture?"
I'm like, "Sure, man."
He pulls out his phone and he just,
again, from over the counter,
he's gonna just take a picture of me.
And I'm like, "Dude, you
gotta be in the picture."
He's like, "Well first
lemme get one of just you."
I was like, "Just get
in the picture, man."
He's like--
At this point you do not have the job
that didn't exist that
you're trying to apply for.
And then he's like,
"No, just let me get one real quick."
And I'm just like, "Okay."
Oh, he's arguing with you.
Yeah, and then he's like...
And then I'm like, "Okay."
And I just kinda stand there
and look at the camera.
And of course I got my mask on,
this is not gonna be a great picture.
And then he was like,
"You're gonna do something?"
Oh no.
"You're gonna give the
peace sign or something?"
He said, "Give the peace sign?"
I don't know what he
said but I was like...
I didn't respond.
At that point I was embarrassed,
cause I'm like, "These people,
they don't know who I am."
And they're all in the
picture, by the way,
Yeah, they're all in the background.
I'd love to see that picture.
And then I'm like,
"Come on out here and
let's get a picture."
So he came around
and the other employee
leaves the other register,
which has somebody at
it to take our picture.
And then there was something
happening with the register
and he had to go to the other register.
And then at that point,
the other employee,
the other teen employee
is picking up on the fact
that errors may be about to be made.
And you can tell he's sensing it.
And he was like, "Did you make sure
"that you put that check in
that check in that envelope
"and that check in that envelope?"
Because we had to go to this register.
And that's the only thing
I'm thinking is like,
"Yeah, exactly.
"Make sure the check is in that
envelope and that envelope."
I think he got there. I
think I figured it out,
but that wasn't one of
my favorite interactions.
Again. I appreciate the enthusiasm.
I get nervous in the lines
because it's nice...
I like it when I see
people who recognize me,
there's like a shudder.
It's like, Hey, it feels...
It's kinda cool.
A lot of people don't get
to experience that moment
of like seeing somebody see you
and they kind of have this
like physical response.
Yeah
And then
the line keeps moving so they
can't do anything about it,
so they're like...
It's like they're just kinda
standing there, shell shocked.
Cause it's the only way
when somebody meets you
that you have permission to just walk away
without saying anything.
So I kind of enjoy that
when being in line,
but then you see them
500 times after that.
So they do have the opportunity
to get the stuff together
so they can say hello.
Yeah, and again,
I don't think it's
possible to talk about this
without seeming like a douche bag
because it's not a very
relatable experience
to get recognized.
So I acknowledged that it's just...
And I do appreciate it
and I don't mind people approaching,
but it's just like there
are certain circumstances
in which it's especially inconvenient,
especially for other people
who are tryna get something done.
And in those circumstances...
Again, I was nice.
I didn't, and then I didn't...
I almost apologized to the
line of people as I left,
but I was just like,
"I'm just gonna leave".
Man just get out of there.
I'll just leave.
Just get out of there.
Disneyland. That was great.
It was great for Lily to be home
and for us to do something as a family,
because she had a number of people to see.
You know, to reconnect with her friends
and stuff like that
for the handful of days
that she was back home.
So it gave us our dedicated time,
because then once we got back,
we did the Thanksgiving lunch,
but then after that,
she was kinda gone seeing other people,
which we totally expected and understood.
And then she's back off at college,
but only just for a couple of weeks
before the Christmas break.
So it was a great experience
being reconnected,
especially cause like we all got along
because we were in the
happiest place on earth
and I wasn't in charge.
Big factor.
I think that really worked.
So yeah, it was a success.
Last thing I'll share
is that usually the
day after Thanksgiving,
we go and get a Christmas tree.
Aha,
We didn't
because the family was
hanging on by a thread.
You know, they're dropping like flies
and I'm just trying not to get sick
so Jessie was in no mood to go get a tree.
And we had decorated a little bit
before everybody got there with like...
There's multiple trees.
There's like four Christmas
trees in our house,
but not...
And they're small.
Like the kids have little ones
and I'm not talking big--
So you're not gonna do
a real one this year?
So Jessie's like, "We gotta
go get the real tree."
And I'm like doing the
math on this and thinking,
so we're gonna put this tree up,
and then we're going back
home to North Carolina,
like mid December.
Yeah.
And then we're not gonna be back
until after the New Year.
And it's like, we're not
gonna have anybody else over.
And I just start realizing
how much of a Scrooge I am
when it comes to the decorations,
cause I'm like the decorations just feel
like they're for us by us
You know what I'm saying?
And so it's like the bias part
is the part that I have trouble with.
Cause I'm like, "Oh, we're
gonna have to get this thing--"
If it's just for you.
We have to do the lights,
but she's like, "But for the kids,
"it's Locke's last Christmas here."
I'm like, "Well, there's lots
of Christmas decorations.
"There's multiple trees.
He's got one in his room."
We haven't yet gotten the tree.
I almost talked her into--
But there are other trees in other places,
but just not...
you don't have a main tree.
We don't have a main real
tree that we put in--
You sound like my dad, man.
They've got--
I mean, Halloween, they
decorated for Christmas.
They got like eight trees.
It's like they live for it.
We got one tree.
Jessie loves it.
I appreciate...
Listen, again, I experienced the benefit
because I didn't help with that.
All I did was went into
the attic and pushed...
My back was already messed up
so I was pushing the boxes to the entrance
and then Locke was taking them down.
And then Jessie is taking this stuff out.
But I don't know.
I think we may have passed
the point of no return
for having a tree.
And then I'm like, "But if we do get one,
"let's get a fake pre-lit tree."
And, listen, I know the
arguments against it.
That's what we have now,
that's what we got last year.
And so here's my question.
I love it.
You take it out and you--
How hard is it to put together?
Easy, three sections
and it's there and then it falls down
and then that's it.
And then you're like,
"This is disappointing."
And then you start hearing the complaints.
It's not a real, it's too short,
It's not this. It's not that.
And then it's like, "But just decorate it.
"And once you decorate it,
"it's fine."
It's fine.
It's fine. You know.
Because all that happens
is the tree basically...
Cause I do all this
stuff to take care of it,
then it basically dies before we leave.
Yeah.
Stops taking water,
and then we get back and it's dead.
And just taking the stuff off of the tree,
causes all the little
needles to go everywhere.
And then you got to take it out
and put it down next to the...
You nearly kill whoever
you're trying to do this with,
trying to get it to the curb.
I mean are there...
Yeah, I'm with you man.
But I know I'm like,
are there pre-decorated trees.
You got pre-lit.
It's like, can you go all
the way, pre-decorated.
You know, just pull out of the boxes.
Jessie's not gonna for that.
You know, it's just like. It's all done.
I will say,
the only thing that I usually
help with is the lights,
which is the worst part
and the top of the tree.
Yeah, I could see why
And so
if the lights are pre-lit I
don't have to worry about that.
I'll put the three sections together.
Are your other trees not pre-lit?
You don't know cause you didn't do those.
I don't...
They're all fake.
Okay, they better be
pre-lit you don't wanna...
I don't think they're a pre-lit.
We're not in the 90s anymore, okay.
Wake up
So anyway, I kind of...
I love Christmas,
I love the holidays,
I like the decorations.
Yeah.
But I'm a little bit of a Scrooge
when I'm like,
"Why are we doing this?"
If we were going to be
here through Christmas
and the whole time, we had a
bunch of people coming over,
Right.
That's not happening.
So am I a Scrooge?
#Earbiscuits?
Yeah. I might give a rec.
I've been really looking forward
to the Peter Jackson
directed Beatles docu-series,
it's called "Get Back."
And I always think that it's on Apple,
but it's on Disney plus.
Yeah.
Cause I looked forever.
I looked all over Apple
and I couldn't find it.
You're looking in the wrong place..
I will say I've only watched
like an hour and a half of it,
which is not much more than half
of the first three episodes.
Is it six hours total or something?
Yeah. It's like he really
Peter Jacksoned it.
So it's the footage leading
up to their last performance.
But they didn't know that
at the time of course.
It was just their first performance
in more than two years
that they were gonna
develop new material for,
to perform for a TV special.
And then they had a documentary crew,
which that's what this footage is from.
It's like film documentary,
and then the release of the album,
which became the, "Let it be" album.
If I'm correct. I believe I am.
So we heard some good stuff about it.
We actually went to a restaurant,
and they said, "How
was your Thanksgiving?"
And the waiter said, "It was great.
"I watched the Beatles docu-series
"and I loved it."
That's apparently all he did.
And I was like, "Oh, it's out."
and I was so excited.
Everyone was talking about it on Twitter,
about how amazing it was.
It's a test of patience and a fandom.
So I'm giving this recommendation couch
and it's not for everybody
because it's just a...
But if you're really into it
is it's an amazing experience,
but don't watch it when you're sleepy,
because it's a fly on the wall,
just footage of them, trying
to pull together physically,
like be in the same space again
and start to write songs.
They're bringing material together
and they're starting to play.
And there's these...
I get goosebumps talking about
the flashes of creativity
where you see Paul McCartney showing up
and George and Ringo in there.
John's not even there yet,
and then he starts writing "Get Back."
Mm-hmm
No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You know, he's like...
The genesis of that song
was fully documented
in that environment under
all of this pressure
and you see all of their personalities
and their interactions.
And I get the impression that
there's not footage like
this of them that exists
because everybody's talking about,
like, I saw Mark Marin tweet,
"They're the guys I always
thought they would be."
but like...
Yes, yes.
And as a huge fan.
There's just, no one has seen--
But I've never hung
out with them like this
Yeah, and people are talking about...
and I've only watched
half of the first one.
and then there's some things
that really start to happen.
Like I know that George leaves,
he quits the band in the midst of this.
So it gets really good, but it's like,
you really have to be committed to it
and you have to be attentive
to the points where the
magic of those moments
is really set up by kinda
like the fly on the wall,
20 minutes of them just interacting.
So it's...
At first I had tears in my eyes,
and then I got bored.
So it's a little bit of both,
but if you push through,
there's these there's these moments
that are just captured,
based on what I've already seen,
that are probably extraordinary.
And it does go, it does go somewhere.
It's just,
maybe I'm in the most boring part of it,
but I'm still recommending it.
"Get back."
All right. Speaking of that,
we will get back with you next week.
Where we're gonna talk about our purchases
from 2021 that we did.
Same thing we did last year going through,
I'm going through all my Amazon.
I think Link is expanding outside of that,
but we're going through
everything that we purchased--
Still gonna be less stuff than you bought.
The highlights of the things
that we bought in 2021.
All right, talk at you next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous episode
of Ear Biscuits, click on
the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.